not afraid to call things aggressively
i'm not afraid if i think we have a good
scheme in a kicking game to call a fake
i'm not afraid to run the ball fourth
and one and we'll play to our defense at
times if we don't get that we've got to
go out there and stand up defense our
defense done that consistently
throughout the year we're going to play
the strengths for our team but look i'm
not afraid to call it aggressively we
went to this game with that mindset so
we've got to do a better job making sure
we coach it the right way execute it the
right way and come out with the results
we want but that being said we're going
to call this thing aggressively we're
going to play it aggressively and when
you make calls like that you let your
players understand that you have
confidence in them and that they can
play the game aggressively so
we have confidence in our players i want
them to play aggressively i can't tell
them all week that they have to go into
this game with an aggressive mindset and
then hold them back at some point when
we feel the chance to make a play it's
tough
that's frustrating not scoring in the
red zone is frustrating that's that's
where we have to be better and if we
were better in that area today things
would have been different why are you
guys as a group having so much trouble
creating separation right now is it
because of the run game i don't know
where people are getting that from uh to
be honest you know creating separation
is that is that what you're saying
it's what the analytics say the you know
the next-gen stats that were that we're
getting what two yards of separation in
nfl that's that's open um you know so i
don't i don't know i don't know what the
analytics say but
you know you can go off that if you want
to i know what i see on film and
for those of them that think that way
you know go look at the film
you'll look at the the game uh
afterwards and realize the red zone
efficiency our defense uh making those
stops is extremely important and we were
three for three in the red zone so uh
yeah colt's a winner he always has been
uh you know i grew up in austin watching
play at texas
he's a winner so uh he's gonna always
have whatever team he's playing for in
the game and so we just have to you know
stay in there and realize that uh as
long as we don't go chasing waterfalls
we're gonna be in the game
oh there he is bigger mayfield that
little smirk we had the feature last
night with all the pop culture
references he has made don't go chasing
waterfalls is a little bit dated though
chris that that probably was from a time
before he was even born i i think you're
right i mean what how old is baker
mayfield 24 25 right around there i mean
don't go chasing waterfalls is like
that's chris sims prime like freshman
years of high school right there right
that's nice walk of seagulls years 19.
i mean yes so whatever the hell the
flock of seagulls are yes that was it
was those years
you don't know what the flock of secrets
is
that
this song from the 80s with the dude
with the blonde hair that was all piled
up on top that was you the night they
put your dad in the ring of honor yes
thank you thank you very much yes
all right we probably have video of that
somewhere if we if we're allowed i don't
know if we're allowed to play that stay
on task here stay on task bears fans
keep the show all right let's go um
browns defeat the giants 20 to six
and
uh
it's this is what the browns do the
browns do not mess around with an
inferior team in all due respect to the
giants yes you were in first place in
the nfc east that does not make you a
good team even though you won a few
games in a row against nfce teams that
doesn't make you a good team the browns
know how
to get the w when they should and i
respect that there are too many good
teams out there that will periodically
step in a pothole against a team that
they should easily beat the packers are
prone to doing that the browns are not
the browns losses this year have only
come against teams that should have
beaten them and they've busted the
narrative recently by beating the titans
and giving the ravens everything they
can handle and
last night was great because it
reestablished the browns on a short week
chris
after they had that heartbreaking loss
it easily could have gone the other way
one loss could have become two right
well they're back and now they've got 10
wins for the first time since 2007 it's
amazing and they're on their way to the
postseason it's not clinched yet and
when you look at both the nfc and the
afc there is a good team that's going to
get kicked to the curb in both
conferences and the browns are still in
danger of being that team but they've
reestablished and baker mayfield has
gotten better and better and better goes
back to the bye week we talked about
that last week it was the bye week when
they had a chance to reassess refocus
regroup and understand what they were
doing going forward and it's worked
credit to the browns and credit the
baker mayfield no it's it's uh it is
amazing i mean they've really have kind
of found their zone you know baker
mayfield last few weeks he's playing his
you know quarterback as good as anybody
in football i mean you really can't
argue that he's on fire for what he's
doing and you're right like the ravens
game they took it as a positive so
that's positive step you know they took
it as and hey we were really the better
team on the field they just had a crazy
guy who was awesome and he beat us but
there was still a lot of good in what
they did and you know they stamped that
home with the performance last night you
know again last night too with baker
mayfield he's just
throwing the ball perfectly and then the
decisions are you know quick and on
point there's no second guessing like we
saw early in the year sometimes with the
the pumping of the ball and you know
re-cocking it back a few times you're
kind of seeing them get back in the
pocket he knows what he's looking for
and he lets that go and that giants
defense last last night
that we've talked about a lot they're
d-line it's as big as anybody in
football they weren't gonna let the run
game beat them they were gonna let make
baker mayfield throw the ball and have
to do it and the way he's throwing it
right now and higgins and landry and
everybody are catching the ball they're
tough to stop you can see here with the
stats i mean doesn't matter play action
down the field blitz whatever it is
baker mayfield is finding the open guy
and hitting receivers downfield for big
plays
and with the colts and the titans
winning and the dolphins winning and the
ravens winning there was pressure on the
browns last night if they had lost they
would have tumbled out of the top seven
in the afc so they desperately needed
that win they did not play like a
desperate team the team that played like
the desperate team last night was the
new york giants multiple occasions in
range for an easy three point oh man
either going for it or dusting off the
playbook
pages that had dust on them for a reason
here's joe judge talking about the
decision on multiple occasions last
night to not take the field goal but to
instead be aggressive because we have to
be aggressive
field goals weren't going to win this
game so look i'm not afraid to call
things aggressively i'm not afraid if i
think we have a good scheme in a kicking
game to call a fake i'm not afraid to
run the ball fourth and one and we'll
play to our defense at times if we don't
get that we've got to go out there and
stand up defense our defense done that
consistently throughout the year we're
going to play the strengths of our team
but look i'm not afraid to call it
aggressively we went to this game with
that mindset so we've got to do a better
job making sure we coach it the right
way execute it the right way and come
out with the results we want
well you know if you close your eyes and
listen to it he talks a lot like john
harbaugh at first i thought it was
harbaugh just hearing the voice oh it's
very similar the rhythm right
right yeah yeah yeah
but but look against teams like the
chiefs i remember when john harbaugh's
ravens playing the chiefs early in the
season got down close on the first drive
you got to get a touchdown you can't get
anything but a touchdown when you're
playing the chiefs the browns aren't in
that same category yet where you've got
to get touchdowns instead of field goals
no you take the points where you can get
them you put the pressure on the browns
offense you slowly apply more and more
pressure you keep it close as long as
you can and then maybe you can steal it
from them late in the game this is not a
team yet maybe they'll get there this is
not a team yet where you always choose
touchdowns over field goals chris that's
my opinion do you agree mike you know me
i'm johnny conservative when it comes to
that stuff i'm always the guy right on
sunday that's going kick the field goal
do you know play the game a little bit
we don't have to win it right now on
play 17 of the first quarter where it's
like we're gonna win the game right now
even though there's 90 more plays to go
for some reason we're going to pick this
one to where it's all going to be
decided i i don't we're in the the age
of analytics and you know when it's
right it's hey analytics are great when
it's wrong it's aggressive and the
analytics told me what are the analytics
ever wrong are they ever wrong i mean
because it just seems like they're
always right but no they're never wrong
numbers never lie no you're always right
they're always right i know you must
defer but there's never a time where
they the analytics say kick a field goal
it's always go for it that's the right
decision right the numbers say go for it
i don't you know i go for it
okay but i'm with you with last night
this game was meant to be
a defensive run the ball struggle type
of football game joe judge is been
kicking butt managing football games he
manages games to a t he really does you
know i understand the aggressive
approach and all of that but yeah last
night i was sitting there on my couch at
home going oh kick the field goal so
what let's go up 9-7 you know what's
let's let's be down 13-9 i just kept
thinking when they scored the late
touchdown in the football game i kept
going man it'd be nice if the game was
20 to 12 right now he's still being a
one score game i'm saying we because i'm
a giants fan so i just i'm surprised by
that approach
especially you know early on they had
shown the ability to stop the browns a
little bit and slow them down it didn't
look like there was nothing to scare you
to go like you're talking about whoa we
can't stop the browns tonight we gotta
score points and we gotta score
touchdowns not field goals there was
nothing that said that that was that was
my only complaint of the football game i
was just mad at that
at the risk of incurring the wrath of
the analytics mafia and let me preface
my comments by saying there definitely
is an important place in the game of
course for this kind of next level
nuanced we talked about it last segment
about drew brees he only had one
interception well it doesn't reveal how
many he could have had that were dropped
by the defensive backs but but
the notion that
taking the outcomes
of specific moments in football games
going back
x number of years thousands of
iterations to get to this final
conclusion that it's 50.1 percent this
way and 49.9 percent that way the thing
that we forget when we do that
is that a coach doesn't have the benefit
of thousands of opportunities to do that
to the point where the trend favors him
if you're an nfl coach you only have so
many of these moments that if you blow
them
you don't have a job anymore
so when you take the next coach and the
next coach in the next coach and you run
it over a course of a generation maybe
the trend goes against what
the guy should have done yeah right but
if you're thinking about now if you're
thinking about winning this game and
doing well in this season and laying the
foundations so you don't get fired after
two or three years sometimes you have to
go against the numbers and that's okay
you have to have someone who's got
the hands on the wheel of the ship
and knows when to steer into the storm
and steer away from the storm and nope i
don't know enough nautical terms to come
up with a good example there but the
point is
the captain knows yeah and needs to be
trusted to know what to do and if we're
gonna let the captain's hands be tied by
just one factor when there are so many
factors
that are driving that decision making
that's not good for the team that's not
good for anybody no i i mean that that i
think you explained it perfectly you're
right there there's a lot there
and it doesn't necessarily always take
into account the particular circumstance
of that day analytics are great but it
doesn't always oh hey is that taking
into account it's a backup quarterback
and a backup running back you know on a
fourth and two situation does that like
increase decrease chances all of those
issues oh hey we're a little banged up
on the offensive line what does that do
to that you know probability of hey go
for it here in this situation okay i
know going for it in this situation the
probabilities are good but how good are
they when i you know are beat up on the
offensive line and we got backups in
what's that what's the probability go to
there that's just where i argue it's a
game where
the giants and colt mccoy we know
they've struggled on offense i mean you
know they beat the seahawks yes they
struggled last week but it's just one of
those things where i looked at it like
get some points early get some
confidence just get the offense going
instead it became like oh man
put two decent drives together and came
away from with nothing damn you know and
that to me was deflating in the football
game overall and gave the browns the
confidence of kind of being in control
throughout and never really being
threatened that way
the good news for the giants they still
are very much alive in the nfc they are
because the team that's in first place
laws look it was a great day for the
dallas cowboys because eagles lost
giants lost washington lost cowboys won
somehow but the giants all they have to
do is catch washington because they
swept washington so
one game back with two games left
and we'll see how it plays out but the
giants can still win that division the
one thing we know from yesterday in the
nfc east the team that wins the division
will not have a winning record so eight
and eight is the best we're gonna get if
washington wins their last two everyone
else has nine losses and there's the
eagles with nine losses plus that one
tie putting them in the basement
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports